in our series the road to 2020 we are
talking to current and prospective
candidates about issues affecting the
country Washington governor jay Inslee
is running a presidential campaign
centered on fighting climate change this
governor he launched a clean energy fund
to invest in new technologies the
Democrat also issued a clean air rule to
cap carbon emissions in the state and
expanded public transit in the Seattle
area Governor NC joins us now good
morning good morning governor let me ask
you this a lot of people think that in
politics right now you can't take on an
issue that is this large the opposite
party of yours the majority opinion in
that party is that human contribution to
climate change is minimal is not the
driving factor how is this gonna get
changed in any significant way through
the political process well through
democracy with people expressing their
voices and they are expressing voices
now we are a scientifically literate
country we just took the first pictures
of a black hole and yet we have a
president United States saying that
climate change is a hoax he says that
when turbines cause cancer look at when
turbines don't cause cancer they cause
jobs and we have a message for America
of job creation we already have three
million people working in clean energy
industries the most rapidly growing job
is in solar installer number two is wind
turbine technician so what is happening
now is people are realizing the economic
potential and job-creating potential of
growing a clean energy economy and
that's why this is rapidly changing
okay you seem to accept though that the
system has to change for this kind of
idea to be tackled you've talked about
for example getting rid of the
filibuster in the Senate so you admit
that the system needs to change and then
the question is think of all the laws
that would have been passed that
Democrats wouldn't have liked in the
last two years if the filibuster hadn't
existed well listen there's nothing
wrong to say democracy can be reformed
and improved we know we need to get rid
of gerrymandering so people actually
have one-person one-vote I believe that
it's time to have popular elections so
people's vote decide who the president
is rather than the electoral college you
want to abolish the Electoral College
needs to go and importantly if this
nation is
going to make any major reforms in
health care in climate change the
filibuster needs to go it's archaic it's
time has passed it's time for us to have
democracy again and movement in this
country how much traction are you
getting on the electoral college a lot
of people say it has to go has to go but
yet here we are a gazillion years later
and it's still here well we are making
progress you know actually we have an
agreement amongst multiple states now to
be bound by the popular vote and we only
needed a few more states right now to
make that compact effective so that you
can essentially effectuate the popular
vote even without a constitutional
amendment this is the popular will we
ought to have one person one vote and we
ought to have the ability to move a
clean energy economy look at I'm the
only candidate who has seen this we're
the first generation to feel the sting
of climate change we're the last
generation who can do something about it
and we have to make defeating climate
change the number one priority I stayed
up last night to watch you late on CNN
Town Hall yeah you seem to be enjoying
it governor I'm a little sleepy this
morning how about you but you said last
night that it's a matter of urgent peril
and great promises I think sometimes so
many people still despite all the
evidence don't get it tell us about the
peril and the promise if you can in one
or two sentences well the peril is right
now the midwest is under floods we've
had billions of dollars in damage we saw
paradise california burned to the ground
we saw ashes on the hoods of cars in
Seattle or force are now burning the
parallel is quite obvious and very
personal I met people a couple in New
Hampshire the other day whose daughter
miss two years of college because of
lime's Lyme disease spread by ticks now
moving north
so the peril is obvious but I think the
most interesting thing is the promise
the promise of clean energy jobs the
promise of giving new people advanced
manufacturing possibilities the fact
that today 3 million people are working
in clean energy industries and I think
that plays to the optimism the can-do
spirit of America I think we're ready
for a president who is who believes we
can do big things again rather than
being fearful hiding behind walls that's
the spirit of America and I think we're
ready for a lead
like that you sure you want this job
yeah I'm ready governor we don't have a
lot of time but real quickly are you for
Medicare for all I'm for Medicare for
those who want it and we are developing
a public option now in my state and I
believe we should have a rapid expansion
of Medicare and I believe that is a very
tenable way because we have to have the
ability of everyone to have health care
and then quickly the largest employer in
your state Boeing the state while you
were governor gave them an eight billion
dollar tax break three hundred forty six
people have died has Boeing adequately
addressed this problem no they have not
and it pains me to say that because they
come from a Boeing family my cousins my
uncle worked in Boeing I'm hopeful that
the Boeing team can can fix problems
with a particular airplane but no
obviously there is a problem that needs
to be redressed and I and should have
been reduced earlier frankly should
their CEO resign I don't know the answer
to that but I know this because you
mentioned the tax issue we should no
longer allow corporations to extort tax
breaks from communities like happened in
my state I believe we should have a
federal law that prevents them for doing
that using the federal tax code to
protect citizens from that type of
activity thank you
you know I covered the governor's race
for Congress 20 years ago when I was a
print reporter for Rolling Rock Road
Road the ferry with Trudy Wright his
wife yeah in a long time one of us is
not aged Thank You governor thanks it's
not Nora
Thank You governor I don't know what you
look like back then I think okay today
we thank you for joining us